want to move on to houston another
person
listen man daryl moore is stepping down
daryl mori stepping down uh i see i'm
looking at your
your your list there and you got yeah
of course mike smith has
quotations
i really do it a lot do i really do it a
lot i did a lot don't worry listen
i'm just teasing you a little bit i'm
self-conscious about it now
step down
so you believe he was uh pushed out look
i don't know what happened daryl mori he
gave he he uh he shot his shot right he
took his shot at it because when he got
there they didn't really have they
didn't have much didn't have a superstar
so he cobbled together all everything
that he had
went at at the time like this is
important to remember went at a bench
player
for the oklahoma city thunder now listen
james harden was not
he was not a bum he was not a bum in
oklahoma city
people thought he had all-star potential
nobody thought this guy was going to
become one of the most transcendent
scorers in the nba that he'd become a
topic he was great in okc he was great
in okc he was the remember he was the he
was the offensive initiator even off the
bench but you're right right nobody saw
this that was one of them
he went all in
he went all in for james harden
he did everything that he could and just
uh it was went heavy on analytics which
is not a surprise you know daryl mori is
a guy who went to northwestern mit he's
the patron saint of analytics in the nba
he's a number savant and so this is this
is what he did uh
he just he applied the numbers to it and
he tried to build his team around that i
was shocked
uh just a perfectly perfect illustration
mike where he trades clint capela
for bob covington i'm like
dude
what what are you doing what are you
doing like
capella is a young big man that's a good
player covington's just a guy but he
went small and he took it as far as it
could go that he didn't leave anything
there based on their talent they got the
most out of their talents so
applause to him applause to whatever
coach he had in place whether it was
d'antoni or anybody else
yeah i don't know i don't know why they
pushed him out though i don't know just
we talked when i say when i say stepping
down when i say stepping down in quotes
i mean it's like listen i don't doubt
and there was another report um you know
saying that it was 100 his decision i
don't doubt that but you know like
whether somebody fires you or you say i
resign there was something about whether
it was you know who they were going to
hire as head coach whether it's another
one with jeff van gundy or the
relationship with tillman fertitta
whatever it was there was something that
forced him
to decide that this ain't for me anymore
i'm out you know what i mean and he look
it was all there was always you know
rumblings anyway that he might be gone
uh even even around the time when when
when d'antoni was done so it wasn't like
daryl mori was secure and this is a
shocker that he's out in houston the how
whether it's him firing being fired or
stepping down is rather immaterial
ultimately that's why i put it in quotes
because at the end of the day it wasn't
working for him and now he's no longer
working for them um
but i'm with you
i do want to start by appreciating what
this man did
because can you have a meaningful legacy
without a title
because if the answer is yes he's got
that uh
ask some of these cats in the
in the nfl in the hall of fame yeah you
can
you can i mean
if you bring about a style of play
if you bring about a trend
that kind of pushes the game from a
different direction
yeah you can that's exactly right
that's exactly right because first of
all
let's just talk about the run he went on
uh
13 years 10 playoff appearances eight in
a row i don't believe any other team has
made the playoffs each of the last eight
seasons i think i think they stand alone
in that that's number one number two
they take the warriors to seven games in
18 and shoot seven to 44 from three so
you want to talk about cruel they should
have at least had one finals appearance
okay
but
beyond that
either the team
or him as a general manager i'm not just
talking about tweets about hong kong
they were never
boring and that's what i appreciate the
most about him you could people could
say oh i hate watching james harden play
or i hate watching him chuck threes
first of all let's go back to his moves
he hate watching him shoot free throws
it's the freaks right yeah i know i know
analytics people love free throws
he never left the stone unturned because
it wasn't just
the james harden trade it was then
bringing the board like
what he did to create room to bring
dwight howard aboard back when that was
a big thing
and we might bring up dwight howard
again later reports about him but
uh bringing dwight howard howard aboard
the team with james hard was a major
three agent acquisition at the time
trading for chris paul
trading for
uh russell westbrook it almost felt like
he was playing with a different set of
rules and a different salary cap because
he always found a way to tinker he was
my kind of general manager you know me
man i like all i know tinker you know
always just around the edges can i move
this piece and this piece here this
receiving is it and bam here's the big
one like he always had something up his
sleeve and i love that about him um
and then again you know he ushered in a
different not ushered it but but
popularized you know oh he did
methodology when it came to basketball
yeah no i i no i think i think you say
it right i think he did usher it in even
though they didn't win a championship so
and and it brought it back if nothing
else they were polarized that's the word
i was looking for they were
polarized
i was about to say provocative but the
same same idea
he was a provocateur i mean he's that
guy i remember draymond green saying a
while ago just kind of hey what's this
analytic you know
he was he was pushing back at analytics
some of the things you're supposed to do
like why would you take a a long two
when you could step back and take a
three it's better value and he was kind
of pushing back and get some of the
stuff and we know analytics some of the
critics of analytics say look it's
it's exclusionary in the wrong way
that it
uh just by its nature
leaves out people of color so there's
some there's some criticism to that
but
daryl mori was was very good at it and
he was inclusive with it shane battier
swears by it shane battier worked with
with the rockets in the front office so
uh for a while now he's working with the
front office with the miami heat
uh he's an analytics guy the reason
shane battier got to houston in the
first place because daryl moore looked
at him and said yes
that's my kind of guy so think about
those guys not just the stars but he
liked chuck hayes he liked shane battier
he looked at
robert covington like a guy with some
size who could shoot threes so he was
doing a little bit different he
evaluated players differently and i've
got to tell you a little a little known
fact about daryl mori
he's a good talent evaluator
when it comes to the front office too
the assistant general manager of the
celtics mike zarin
was hired by daryl mori and it came down
to check this out came down to in the
higher it came down to mike zarin who's
still there
and the director of analytics for
twitter now
so he looked at both of these guys said
hey you guys have it so one guys
assistant gm of the celtics one guy is
running twitter analytics is there is
there is there tell me if this is a
stretch i could just i'm just
spitballing tell me this is a stretch is
there a a a billy bean comparison is
that is that apt as somebody who kind of
who really kind of revolutionized the
way teams were constructed and the way
they played the game but never really
got over the hump with that but other
teams copied the approach and maybe had
success for whatever reason because
every because everybody constructs teams
you know with you know it with with
threes and free throws and for the most
part you know i mean the lakers almost
turn back the clock by going big again
but but small ball is like
you know everybody does it now
every step of the way
that analogy doesn't fall apart
there's nothing about the billy beam
daryl mori uh analogy that falls apart
it doesn't
you think about okay neither one of them
won a championship so that's where the
the hater and you comes out and said
okay yeah yeah that's great that's cute
but you didn't win a championship
so there the critics are the same there
are people who paid attention to it
uh there are people who who looked at
the guys they got the guy himself
he said okay what what is this
that you were annoyed by it
but you were drawn to it so every step
of the way
uh that that billy bean daryl mori hey
this is a different way to look at the
game and some of the traditionalists
didn't like it
there were managers who who worked for
billy bean who said you're kind of
devaluing
what i do
and think about it there was friction
between mike d'antoni and daryl mori at
times
you know they talked about the contract
so it really that's a good comparison
mike i think that's that's it yeah
one of those teams i don't i don't think
it's the fact that they never got over
the hump is somehow an indictment a
referendum that the methodology or was
flawed they just it happens man i mean
not to mention they unfortunately were
in the time of the warriors you know
maybe there's inherent flaws with with
james harden in his ability uh to
perform at a high level you know you
know in critical moments maybe it's not
it might not be about the system or
analytics it just maybe it wasn't in the
cards for them but like i said the
legacy is there speaking of hard though
um
what does this mean for them they they
feel kind of stuck like they feel like
one of those things talk about the
clippers just running it back they feel
like a roster that's just really going
to run it back maybe they look different
obviously different head coach maybe
it's jeff van gundy um but it doesn't it
doesn't feel like there's a whole lot of
options for them in terms of what they
can do um as a franchise to try to
improve
or remember
that's all they got that's it
um
you know how much
how much further are you going to go
with
with russell westbrook and james harden
in the west with somebody what would
somebody trade them for james harden
that would make it worth their while
that's what i'm wondering too like even
if they want to blow it up could they
with that with that contract and the
money they owe him yeah or james harden
yeah you think somebody would give him
enough to make it worth that while to
unload him if okay i'm not even sure
they want to blow it up well i was gonna
say it depends on what they're trying to
do
because you know what if they if they
blow it up if you trade if you trade
james harden i'll tell you who you are
you know
it's funny it's just so weird there's so
many slots in the they're like three or
four slots in the nba not more okay
there's a terrible team slot right
there's a lottery so you're in a lottery
that's one then your championship level
and then there's that that first second
round
i'm gonna call it the
oklahoma city slot if you trade james
harden you get a bunch of picks in
return you get a young player with
potential you're oklahoma city who you
just beat in the first round in seven
games like the the line is so thin
between houston and oklahoma city and
maybe the line is james harden
yeah you get james harden out of there
but as long as somebody else you're okc
but as long as he's on the team even if
they play differently even if even if a
jeff van gundy or somebody comes in and
convinces james harden to give up the
ball even if they play a different style
of basketball it's still a playoff team
they're gonna miss the playoffs you know
they're still good enough to so to your
point they're not a championship caliber
team
you know and it's still a few steps away
from bottoming out enough to you know to
start to start fresh here's the most
interesting angle to this though i've
been waiting to get to this uh gary
throw those tweets back up again because
i
i didn't i i wasn't on twitter but i did
find it on the internet
as i was just kind of you know perusing
for a reaction
uh to james harden my man uh shay
serrano
from the ringer look at this tweet at
the very bottom
look at one at the bottom michael daryl
moore take over the texans please i'm
begging you
yo that's like a thing though
that's like a thing
nobody i mean the idea of him pulling a
paul d podesta going back to the i'm
connected look at look at that look at
look at that look at that full circle
connection right there pulling the paul
d podesta who went from you know the
dodgers i believe was his last stop
before he went to the bronze
okay and not that that's worked out
famously but nonetheless there's
precedent for crossing over from sports
here are the texans
you know they have jack easterbee as
their interim general manager he's
already in houston i don't think daryl
mori's
intellect or management style is
exclusive to basketball with the right
personnel evaluators around him
you know you already said he's got an
eye for talent
i'm intrigued i'm intrigued by him
you should be more than intrigued
we should stay on top of this
this is going to be on your list
sometimes so it's going to be in your
feed mike's feed okay it's going to come
up it's going to be mori 2 and it may
not be the texans but it's gonna be a
team in another sport i'm gonna tell you
why
one
daryl moy before he got into basketball
basketball was not where he thought he
was going he was initially part of a
ownership group to buy the red sox
so he thought and he worked for bill
james
so he thought he was going to work at
baseball
he wanted to work in basketball but he
thought he was going to work in baseball
and so he was ready for that
so the guy who was going to work in
baseball goes to business business with
the celtics not front office he's
working in the business department then
goes to basketball in the front office
with the houston rockets i would not put
it past him it's not an outrageous tweet
chase serrano give you props maybe
a it's a it's a tweet that makes you
laugh
but it's a tweet that is very real no no
there are no there are reports there are
reports of nfl insiders no that's not
just shay there are reports from nfl
insiders
who are saying
that their sources are telling them that
again based on the depodesta precedent
for example like amore
mori running an nfl team again with the
right staff
is not a stretch and that he couldn't be
successful now listen man it'd be hard
to i have a hard time believing that you
know another
20 some odd teams in the nba that nobody
would be interesting interested
and you know by extension that daryl
mori wouldn't find them interesting for
him to have another nba stop
but if he wanted to stay put in houston
and take on an interesting challenge and
we just talked about how he found a way
to maneuver you know around the rules
and and the system and and move you know
i think two three steps ahead
what are the texans devoid of draft
capital
you know they got a roster that's a
smart trade and they're devoid of
they really struggle with placing value
on their own players
and other players
like other people look at players and
say we don't want them anymore and the
texans
under bill o'brien said sure
we'll take them and it's been some bad
moves they've overpaid they've overpaid
for other players and they have not
gotten value on their great players that
they've traded uh namely uh deandre
hopkins
but there have been there have been
others too i mean they they didn't
really get much
uh when they moved on from jadav and
county either
but hey pay attention
to the good one
this is good i'll just say this as we go
to i say this as we go to break i'd
rather worry end up with the nfl team
than the nba team at this point
you